In our high fives and smiles study, measuring smiles was an objective measure.
That is, it's something that we can actually see and measure. However, we could
have also asked the fellow Udacians to rate their level of happiness when I
gave them a high five. In asking them to rate their happiness, we use a
self-report measure. And, this is a subjective measure. Now, I want to have
Susan here give you more examples of different objective and subject measures.
Another type of objective measure is a physiological response. Heart rate is
one example of a physiological response, sweating is another physiological
measure. Physiological measures are also objective because we can quantify
those responses. For the heart rate, we can use pulse to determine heart rate.
Sweating, we can measure temperature and we can also measure the galvanic skin
response. One problem with self-report measures is that we can't be sure
they're completely accurate. But that is the only we can get that information
is to ask the participant. Think that to Lorens reaction who tickles the snake.
We could use different psychological measures to assess her response. We can
use an objective measure meaning we could watch her run away. We could also
look at her nervous laughter and that would be an objective measure. We could
also ask self report. Hey Loren, how did you feel when you saw that snake. A
physiological objective measure. We could have measured her heart rate, which
would have increased due to her fear response. We could have also measured her
sweating. Most psychological experiments try to get both objective and
subjective measures.